[Music]
here at lad Bible we've come to a
decision we're going to start our own
country seems a bit ridiculous well it's
about to get them also there's been a
huge mucking issue growing over the last
20 years that everyone has conveniently
turned a blind eye to plastic waste 8
million tons of plastic get dumped into
our oceans every year there is so much
of it that in the North Pacific
there is now an area of trash the size
of France with no one doing anything
about this country size problem we
thought we would by turning it into an
official one so welcome to the trash
Isles we teamed up with a plastic ocean
foundation and on World Oceans Day we
submitted a declaration of independence
to the United Nations to seek
recognition of the trash Isles as an
official country if we can make it a
country we are protected by the UN's
environmental charter which states all
members shall cooperate in a spirit of
global partnership to conserve protect
and restore the health and integrity of
the earth's ecosystem which essentially
means by becoming a country others are
obliged to clean us up we only have four
criteria we need to hit for the UN to
recognize the trash Isles
we need to be able to define a territory
check form a government check be capable
of interacting with others check and
lastly we need a population which is
where you lot step in your signatures on
our petition will help force the UN to
approve our application become a citizen
of the trash Isles today and help ensure
the world's first country
trash is its loss
[Music]
you